So, you receive your invitation...
...and the first thing you start thinking about is...
..."What am I going to wear?"
There's a dress code for Harry and Meghan's wedding,...
...which is for the ladies to wear hats.
It's absolutely very traditional in a British wedding.
Here in the US, we don't wear hats to weddings,...
...but rather we dress to the nines.
Most weddings are formal attire or black tie.
In the UK, it's traditional for the best man's speech...
...to be a little bit risque.
Sometimes, they bite a bit close to the bone,...
...tells them embarrassing stories about the past.
With speeches like that, we would definitely be surprised...
...because here, it's a toast not a roast.
Meghan has ordered a lemon and elderflower sponge cake...
...from the American baker, Claire Ptak.
In the UK, it's traditional to have a fruitcake with a marzipan icing,...
...which is usually tiered and it's usual to save the top layer...
...for the first child's christening.
In the US, couples get to choose their cake and filling.
Cake tasting is absolutely the best part about wedding planning.
You get to taste your specific cake, tailored to you,...
...design it to your liking and absolutely choose your flavor.
A classic favorite of all American weddings is, of course,...
...bubbly: champagne and sparkling wine.
There's really nothing better.
We understand that Meghan's favorite wine is Tignanello from Italy.
Personally, I prefer champagne.